I was six years old when I started figure skating.
It was really hard to just spin and just skate,...
...so I fell a lot, but I'd still think it was really fun.
Young You is a three-time South Korean national figure skating champion.
She was just 11 years old when she won the title for the first time,...
...making her the youngest in history.
She also qualified for the Winter Olympics in 2018.
When I was 14, I qualified in the Olympics,...
...but I was too young to compete in the Olympics, sadly.
Young You has a rigorous training schedule,...
...which has her traveling the globe.
I trained in Colorado, in Japan and Korea.
I'm now working on my triple axel.
Triple axel is spinning in the air like three and a half rotation.
That is the hardest jump in the triples.
After that, I'm working my quad style with the harness.
The quad style is turning in the air four rotations,...
...so it's the hardest jump that I'm doing.
Being a figure skating champion is hard work,...
...but Young You is motivated by the support of her family.
Sometimes, I'm not good as usual, but my mom supports me and gives me love,...
...so it helps me, and all my families are...
...cheering me up and makes me do more hard work.